be a little bit more of a class than a
kind of a lecture presentation I learned
something about marketing because I was
told that the title of this initially
was how to negotiate when you absolutely
have to have the deal well that is a
great time een that's a title that you
would you'd come for I mean everybody
would come to hear how you how do you
negotiate when you have to have the deal
you know everybody wants to know how to
do that they asked me you know what were
you teaching and I would say don't get
in that position where you absolutely
have to have the deal so it'd be a very
short session so I changed the session
to the one that you you signed up for
which is conducting effective
negotiation a little more pedestrian
title a little less exciting but I think
we'll go over some things here that may
influence the way you think about
negotiations so who in here likes to
negotiate raise of hands so that's maybe
20% of the class who just dreads
negotiation that's even a smaller
position so the rest of you are kind of
indifferent you'll do it you know you'll
eat your broccoli if you have to but
you're not looking forward to this is
the negotiation is the vegetables of
your business life you'll do it you know
it's good for you you know you have to
do it but you don't absolutely love it
so who and let's just take a second on
those of you who like it why do you like
it what is it you like about it now the
hands disappear yeah compared to my
engineering field when I knew everything
was right or wrong black or white in
negotiations everything's great and
nobody can say I'm wrong okay so you
feel better about yourself you don't get
any bad at you I get credit you know
he's okay
have done it better yeah right yeah the
reason I want to negotiate is that
typically I have highest potential a
blind negotiate I'm gonna wing I'm going
to get feathered on the other side so
you're going to improve your irritation
the situation okay so you negotiate to
improve whatever situation you're
involved in in complex situations is
just rarely the case that you can make a
deal without some level of negotiation
so I look at as just as as a means to
the end and get into the end is kind of
the goal on the flip side doing win-win
deals is really a lot of fun okay so
you're seeing largely as eating your
broccoli but sometimes you do get to
turn it into I can't think of your first
George Bush you made the comment about
how you hated eating broccoli so I
actually like broccoli food yeah yeah I
think the weed weed is fun and it's also
like a pizza it's like putting in a
puzzle another person what do I want to
get all
they work and you look at the window
that's fun everything's so win-win
agreements are fun and you and you can
negotiate the higher the percentage of
deals you can get there win-win the more
you like it other you got opportunity
for creativity
it's one of the most creative aspects it
does allow you to fashion solutions
according to usually different kinds of
facts different fact situations so you
get to be you get to express some
creativity other things yeah we have a
big relationship as always young person
building you understand better where
what they want where they want to go and
you can discover some more and I'll bet
you those of you said you didn't like
negotiations sought as a way of
destroying relationships of stressing
out relationships so a lot of it depends
on and you know what are you doing to
relationships as you negotiate with
other parties how about those of you who
didn't let's get some more things you
don't like about notion for those are
just sayin I could do without this what
you're not like yeah it makes me very
uncomfortable thing to think that I do
not have enough information to get the
most out of this negotiation and more
often than that I just read the results
thinking I could have done better okay
so you look back on it and you say shoot
I got taken I didn't get as good a deal
as I might have gotten I lost other
things you don't like about yeah
this is the time hopefully the person on
the other side is where our is an
intelligent team you're dealing with but
you do get the what I call amateur like
if I pound on the table that's an effect
of the effect you get just
intellectually and emotionally tiresome
you can get abused in negotiation and
there's a whole lot of there are a lot
of issues around power and information
if there's a disparity in power leverage
information and you're dealing with a
party who's going to use that and take
advantage that you can go out of the
room feeling abused yeah yeah I actually
met with Donald Trump in his office in
New York about 20 years ago before he
was a huge cheese but he was whatsit
yeah well no he still had the same hair
it actually tried to sell me an interest
in the Washington Generals there you
know the Washington Generals this was a
USFL football team that had drafted
Herschel Walker and so he was very proud
of that and he was trying to sell me an
interest in that and I didn't fall for
it so that's my qualification for
teaching a class on negotiation actually
my qualifications is I I have negotiated
billions of dollars of transactions over
the years literally hundreds if not a
thousand different kinds of transaction
I was in the real estate business for 20
years and I was actually the chief
financial officer of a big real estate
company over about ten years so I was
negotiating debt deals and equity deals
and then partner departures and solving
litigation and so my life was a diet of
negotiate just solid diet of
negotiations and then when I got done
with that I started buying companies and
it became a different diet of
negotiation so I've seen a lot of
different kinds of negotiations I have
experienced the feeling of looking
forward to a day when I'm negotiating it
with great anticipation and really
loving it because I like the people on
the other side I like trying to
problem-solve I like being creative I
like all those those element
and I also have looked at certain days
of negotiating where I dread it I cannot
wait to get the day behind me so there's
nothing intrinsic about negotiations
that say you should like it or not like
it I remember teaching a real estate
class here at Stanford about ten or
twelve years ago and asking the class
roughly the same question but I did in
the form of who of you likes to buy a
new car and that was the most highly
correlated question with who likes to
negotiate and who doesn't there are some
people who absolutely hate the process
of buying a new car because it feels
like you come out a little dirty you
don't have the it's an uneven
information uneven power than whatever
so it can it can be a bad experience
well who here our expert negotiators
raise of hands every hand should go up
every hand in the room should go up you
all are here in life because you have
been superb negotiators you would not be
and what does negotiate negotiation is
getting what you want at a price that's
acceptable to you so you have paid
prices to be at this place in your life
that you're happy with so you are expert
negotiators and I want to ventilate that
a little bit and let you really kind of
peer into what it is that you're you've
been so good at but first of all here's
maybe a little bit of a map for you
start thinking about the terrain of
negotiation all of the conversations you
have in if you think broadly about it
everything that you've done has been a
negotiation for those of you who are
married you're negotiating all the time
with your spouse with your children in
your job you're negotiating all the time
in school you're negotiate I mean
conversations are in effect a
give-and-take and you and there's a give
get transaction and usually the more
informal they are the more successful
people feel when you do with friends and
family
usually they feel more successful then
you get into these sort of style where
we think about negotiations entrepreneur
is in this area of stylized negotiations
where there are agreements there are
certain things that we negotiate we sit
down at a table somebody takes notes we
write it up and there are certain things
that we trade off and then finally very
formal negotiations these are typically
ones that are done in arbitration or
litigation where there are rules of
evidence where is a very structured
narrow thing and that one is not a very
fun one although I've now spent four
years in litigation I'm good enough at
in fact I had one attorney say that I
was the best witness he had ever run
into and I started liking negotiation or
litigation after that this is an
opposing attorney too so you feel pretty
good about that so what makes for
successful negotiations in across all of
those if a man I recognize so many
people from my past in here it's going
to be hard not to cold call on Angie
here FAA here Nichola so what makes for
successful negotiate if you think about
successful negotiations what do you
think about I've just had a successful
negotiation
what's your self-talk yeah okay
expectations are your expectations
you've set them the right way going in
they've been met therefore you've
achieved your objectives that's a
successful negotiation yeah
okay
it's also why everything is interested
in walks not oppressors how do we
perceive that how do we find all that is
fun online how that is something I
should perform and this is stress okay
so some of it is how you use how you
define the terrain how the other are you
and the other party perceive it and then
are you able to execute in that
perceived terrain bunny on the other
side is that the person that the
residual effect after they walked out
the room and as time goes on but they're
not upset and don't kind of undermine
the negotiate whatever the results were
so they were happy to if you all are
thinking more broadly than a lot of
business people think about negotiation
I mean these are what I would call
enlightened comments about negotiation
here's what most business people are
negotiating this is the essence of most
business agreements these five things so
they're focused on getting the best
price getting the most attractive terms
making sure that whatever time frames
for execution or deliverables whatever
are acceptable making sure the
warranties are in place and then if
things go wrong they've got remedies
they may be legal remedies they may be
economic remedies they're probably a
combination of both
so most business negotiation which is in
this stylized category in the middle is
so focused on me getting what I want in
these five areas and people don't think
more broadly than that if
people who do a lot of negotiating
around these things talk about these
techniques does anybody not run into
these before as sort of things that are
taught in negotiation class or any of
these new to any of you surprising the
bathroom one is a is a commonly used
technique feed the person a lot of water
and a lot of food and then just keep
talking keep the pressure and so using
the bath bathroom breaks is a powerful
if you're using techniques you know the
and what do I mean by plane they've got
a plane to catch their schedule exactly
they've got to catch a plane and so you
just carry on the negotiations you speak
slowly you make things drag out you
disagree at the last minute as they're
running for their planes oh you do the
Columbo thing you know oh one more thing
you know have any of you been subject to
any of these what does it feel like
that's what you have to assess whether
it's it's it's almost clean competence
or is it actually bad faith and that can
be difficult and it's annoying to have
to even
either case William how do you feel
you're dealing with an incompetent party
or a bad actor [ __ ] we're the worst
angry
very few people don't recognize please
if you're on the other side tape it's
not like oh my gosh what is happening I
don't know I don't understand this is
sure working on me you know most of the
time you perceive immediately these
techniques and you resent them you're
angry about this so in terms of
techniques that people teach you know I
think these are anti successful
agreement techniques you may get a deal
done but you're unlikely to get a deal
that is lasting enduring flexible where
you build relationships where you create
solutions but these are used all the
time mostly by investment bankers I'm
just kidding sorry sorry I know could
you turn the tape off up there
their technique which I've run into
quite a lot of dealing with competitors
which is the during Alvin a set of
complex long line negotiations over the
course of months the you discover that
in the course of the supposedly good
faith negotiation the competitor for
example has been actually promoting
something completely different we're
talking to somebody else and the
explanation you get when you protest is
I'm very sorry we had no idea that was
going on yeah the improvisation on
Android isn't it yeah
or just innocent you know I had no idea
or oh my god yeah yeah which puts you on
your heels puts you at a disadvantage
maybe there are others anybody in here
experienced other too obvious techniques
that are being used to gain power yeah
John we were yeah we just climbed out
the window but there are a lot of
interesting stories there's another one
so yeah
yeah and so I had a translator
unfortunately and so that was one kind
of an interesting barrier because I was
pretty sure that he understood English
and a variety of reasons and smoke was
also another gaved smoker and I can't
stand smoking and I tried my hardest to
make sure that he didn't know that is
certainly an affected kind of the way
it helps I want to spend in this 4x8
room yeah it's very interesting so
making things physically uncomfortable
or getting a leg up too late there's
another way that I see it language used
in that is abusive language you know
people that start dropping f-bombs or
shouting you know cursing at your
whatever they believe they get a leg up
and in some ways most of us kind of
react we go a little bit on our heels
when somebody starts cursing at us or
they raise their voice or something I
mean as tough as you may be if somebody
starts doing that there's something in
the inner child of all of us that
recoils a little bit and is back on our
heels a little now it can cause you to
come back in like manner it can cause
you to get to that level yourself which
may or may not be a good thing coming so
I actually the opposite happens to me
once where we were having issues and
couldn't come to an agreement
and they came back and they were
actually you know they could do more
more than what they were saying they
gave me everything so they were treating
me with kindness and then they went on I
went back and change it again so it was
opposite of using the abusive language
so it's kind of a limp leg you know and
yeah where people use different
techniques to deceive Andy so do I have
a feeling you're gonna tell us ways to
actually do this that aren't these ways
but let's see these guys examples where
you actually are faced with people like
this on the other side the table and how
do you actually take control or sort of
set it on a positive tone especially
your situation where you're sort of
feeling like this is the company I
really want to buy or this is the job
that I really want to get yeah and you
don't really have as many options but
these people are excelling at you with
these techniques yeah what would you
advise us to do well let's have the
group I'll give you my the way I react
to it but anybody in the group you know
somebody is using one or more of these
on you yeah so calling them on it is one
really affected a you know I've actually
done this in a in a litigation where the
opposing attorney was deposing me and he
stood up and got right in my face and
started to shout at me saying why did
you do such and such and you know it
really is off-putting and you're all it
shows in the transcript is why did you
do that's all it shows that's all it
shows and if you answer the way you're
feeling when somebody gets in your face
and shouts at you and a cute and
accusatory way you say will you son of a
guy tell you the reason you know and
you'll do it in a way that isn't
effective most effective thing that I
found was exactly what you're saying I
say why are you standing up and raising
your voice I mean that goes on the
record but it's so that's that's the
most
you know copied down way of doing
exactly what you're saying is you really
call Emma in a nice way why are you
raising your voice what makes you shout
about that question why are you standing
up but why are you pacing the floor as
you get all of it on the record now you
don't need to get it on the record in a
normal negotiation but calling them on
it is one thing what's another way that
you could deal with that questions
that's where I start questions are very
effective you know just asking just
posing questions you know that's always
a very inoffensive way of taking the
volume level down getting information
cooling people off another way planks
enduring this type of mode the other
person's on good faith most emotions
we're going to be doing you need to have
a relationship and it the relationship
is usually a lot more important than the
actual deal you finally end up with a
lot of cases so I mean I think you do
have to call them on you have to say you
know what's your purpose here and you
guys if he's doing one you're doing
another it doesn't make sense you guys
have to be both wanting to deal both won
best and win win anything to get here
have such power and such an advantage
and you really do need the deal that
they get away with more that it's tough
to raise them to that level when there's
such a disparity in terms of information
or power that it can be very tough to do
I'll tell you what I try to do is make
it completely ineffective just make it
so either I ignore it I just don't pay
attention to what it is they're doing
by that I mean I don't drink water you
know I am able to out let my bladder is
better than their bladder you know or I
I will plan my trip with an extra night
of hotel room and I'll have an extra
flight out the next day so I'm not eat
anxious but I'll let them know I'm
leaving at five o'clock tonight but
oftentimes they'll push the thing and I
just don't sweat it we stay and then I'm
pretty soon to me it becomes a question
well let's keep staying here let's keep
working you know I've missed my plane
let's work it's 11:00 at night no
problem I can keep working well I mean
you kind of make it so that the game
that they've set up hurts
them so they really pay the price for
whatever again is so make it ineffective
so these techniques really can sometimes
work marginally in the short run on some
people but they're not really very
powerful long term techniques now if you
look at textbook discussions of
negotiation you run into these terms and
I'm not going to talk about the tech I
want to talk really today about very
practical real-world situations but
these are this is the terminology the
writing so I know some of you are going
to take classes or have taken classes in
negotiation these will not be unfamiliar
terms to you in the lexicon of
negotiation so here are some practical
keys to successful negotiation and these
will look just so simple minded which is
in fact what most really practical
things are born of experience but the
first thing is negotiate with the right
party I'm going to tell you a half a
dozen stories here before we wrap up
where you'll see how I learned these
particular lessons I think but get with
the right party you would be amazed at
how many negotiations go on with the
wrong party with the unempowered
lieutenant with somebody who really is
not the decision-maker whatever so
figure out who the right party is and
are you talking with the right party
secondly is become a trusted negotiator
I put here that's a function of CCP and
my students will recognize as a bunch of
character competence and power for
somebody to be trusted they have to be
high character they have to be competent
and they have to be empowered to make a
decision so you want it the right party
for you to negotiate with is somebody
you can trust the right party for them
is that you must be also trusted so if
you want to enter high-quality
negotiations getting high levels of
trust based on character competence and
empowerment are really important things
to assess then know your own Batna
what's a Batna
in unison best alternative to negotiated
agreement okay this is a term that was
developed by Fisher and ury in 1981 out
of the Harford negotiations study which
they really found that if people could
go into a negotiation with an idea of
what is their best alternative to this
six this negotiation working out
successfully they came out with better
end results you go in with far more
confidence I've taken it to another
level what I go into negotiations now is
I figure out I don't know it for sure
but I try to assess what is the other
parties Batna so I really think hard
about what is it they want to achieve
and what are their options because that
really helps you kind of assess the
whole thing you're not just thinking my
agenda my agenda my agenda here's what I
want
price term remedies Warren this is what
I need and so many negotiators are going
in with their own agenda well go in and
think about what is the lay of the land
for the other party that helps we'll
talk a little bit later about Fisher and
Yuri's map but I think there are three
or four suggestions that they make that
are kind of their broad map they're
really very helpful this certain the
difference between battles and Wars what
we used to call the elephant ant some
people don't know the elephants from the
ants have you ever negotiated with
somebody for whom every deal point is
something that they have to win you know
everything is competitor on up they have
to win every deal point I'm here to
submit to that's a really dumb way to
negotiate this is a given to your if
you're going to try to develop
relationships the way Nicola said or if
you're going to try to come out with
creative solutions or whatever you
really don't want this I have to win
every deal point think so know where the
elephants are and where the answer be
willing to you to lose some battles to
win the war yeah
tear out in the first place oh isn't
wouldn't it be trying back put points
there that I know I don't feel so
strongly about yeah when the other part
of you doing the same thing they should
be and you should I mean in really
effective sort of win-win negotiations
you share with what you're trying to
achieve Lee Iacocca has a great line you
know he was the guy that turned around
Chrysler and he said you know when I
want to achieve something I tell the
other party exactly what it is I'm
trying to achieve and what price I'm
willing to pay to achieve it and that's
really kind of the starting point where
it's it's sharing in front there so
there's a lot more sharing of
information in that kind of a model of
negotiation
it doesn't always it's not always
something you can do and then I you know
getting back to these techniques I would
say don't worry too much about taking so
you have to be aware of them you have to
be good and it tells you something if
somebody's using I always think when
somebody's shouting at me or walking out
of the room or throwing things there's
information in that it's like I had a
partner one time in the real estate
business who looked at a joint venture
document that was this thick and he
looked at any picture he said in any
document that's that thick there's
something in it for me
and in a way anybody who's throwing
things and screaming and shouting and
slamming doors or locking you in rooms
or anything like that there's something
in that for you you know you can get the
high moral ground you can at least get
information so don't worry too much
about them but be aware of them and then
really understand what the other party
this is kind of back to the figuring the
other person's better but if the more
you can understand their values and I'll
tell you stories in a minute that
illustrate each of these the more you
can understand really what it is that
drives them what's important to them the
more likely you are to craft a solution
to things that satisfies what it is
that's important to them so here you've
all seen this before just to pause on it
for a second those of you who dread
negotiations probably have experienced
some of this win-lose experience those
of you who said you really enjoyed them
probably
experience more of the the left-hand
column
okay so here's seven situations that
have sort of Illustrated these points
let me Anna and I only tell you these
not because I've had some unique
negotiating experience but because you
may recognize in some of these things
your own experience you may be able to
tie it into your own experience and
internalize it in your own way so that
really does belong to you the first one
I taught a negotiation session in the
real estate course here at Stanford it a
number of years ago and I had a version
one and version 2 of this inversion one
the instructions were I want you all to
have fun so this was the three party
negotiation there was a buyer there are
two or three properties a buyer a seller
and a lender and they had to come up
with a tripartite agreement and so
everybody went off in these negotiating
teams and made deals
the instructions were have fun be
creative learn everything you can about
real estate everything and then just
report back on your experiences well
here's what happened there were
reasonable deals made they were made
quickly they were relatively easy to
understand and document and there was a
lot of camaraderie people came out of it
saying man this is this was a fun
exercise we like each other aren't
Stanford MBAs cool I just really love my
classmates so that was kind of the
outcome so that's the negotiation 1.0 so
then we changed the instructions
okay the objective is to win you know
you're going into this negotiation the
ideas you want to win your grades going
to be influenced by it and the results
are going to be published in ranked
order and you need to make a report on
how you feel about it what would you
guess the change in results was yeah
fewer deals were made they were made
more slowly a lot more time was expended
I mean tons more time people said this
negotiating exercise took longer and was
tougher than anything they had done at
Stanford we're frustrated and they hated
their classmate
they said I will never do business with
these turkeys again I had no idea these
people were such jerks you know so it
fundamentally changed by the mindset and
I set up the mindset which means my
fault but the economic outcomes weren't
any bet they were fewer as somebody
pointed out a lot more complex deals a
lot of more unworkable undocumented
unenforceable and the interpersonal
relationships restrained so you can see
by having this mindset if we've got to
win and it's zero-sum and it was defined
I mean there was so I mean there's so
few things in most business negotiations
that was so little data that was price
terms time frames warranties and
remedies were about the only thing
people could work with I mean they went
in and just pummeled each other just
beat each other to bloody pulps so
that's the first story and I'll let you
draw your own conclusions from these the
second one is when I was first starting
in business I had a deal that I was
working on in osku or they say Aska
Spain I do that right any of the Spanish
speakers vodka and we were going into a
bank there to borrow money and we walked
in and it was clear within a few minutes
that they really weren't quite expecting
us there so they ushered us into this
office with a guy that said oh well you
know and so he sat down to listen to us
and as we were sitting there negotiating
over financing this office building two
guys in white coats came in and they
took the painting off the wall then a
few minutes later they came back in and
took the credenza and then they
unplugged the phone and walked out with
the phone pretty soon they came in and
took the desk put it on a dolly and went
out with it we're sitting there in these
chairs talking and all of the furniture
has been moved out well it turns out
this guy was not really the person who
had anything to do with life he was just
a courtesy party who said well these
guys are here that from the United
States make them feel good and so the
negotiation went oh well this kind of I
will tell you the my point on this it
goes back to make sure you're negotiated
with the right party we had absolutely
the right this guy could not have made
any deal with us whatsoever but we
didn't check it out so
sat there talking across an empty office
about a deal it was never going to
happen well that's an extreme example of
something that we all do a lot of times
we end up negotiating with parties
without power without the ability to
make a decision so you really want to
think that through the third one was
also early on in my career I was a chief
financial officer in my late 20s of a
big big company and I was supposed to
make a joint venture with a life
insurance company and so I'd studied all
the joint ventures have been I'd figured
out what I wanted on this deal and what
a win-win I mean I had all I was steeped
in all these things and so I sat down
with the very senior 50-ish life
insurance executive and we started to go
through the deal points and there were
eight or ten of them and about after
I've been said no we're not going to do
that and about the eighth deal point I
rose Rosalind the ninth deal point and
said you know we'd really need to have
this one you've said no on eight of them
and he said Joel sit down just take
notes your job here is just to take
notes you know we're not negotiating
anything just take notes we're the life
company we've got all the money you're
just the developer take notes and so it
was clear to me that what that
negotiation was about that negotiation
was not going to be won in in that
series of discussions but I was really
going to just document it in a way that
we had a chance to do our business and
we had options in the future you know so
that wasn't the only option that I had
limited partners I recall early on
thinking that I wanted to develop a
brand I wanted to be seen as a certain
kind of negotiator and I part of my
brand was going to be that I would
calculate exactly what a deal was worth
and then I wouldn't budge on the price I
was I wanted to be known as somebody who
knew the value of what it was I was
offering and so if I said this is a
million dollar investment
I didn't want to settle for 950,000 you
know I really wanted to say it's a
million dollar and I guess if you want
to trade two nickels for a dime I'll do
that but I'm not going to trade a dime
for one nickel so I really wanted that
to me my brain because I realized I was
going to be in this business a long time
and do hundreds of deals so in
negotiating with these limited partners
I became very stiff on this and it was
only when I got options and what
happened to me and this in in one case
was a guy said well I'm not going to do
the deal I need to do the deal at nine
hundred and fifty thousand not a million
I went out that night and called another
limited partner investor group and said
I'll tell you what if you'll do this
deal at a million dollars I can document
the deal tonight and I can give you all
these other things but I need the
agreement tonight so when the guy called
up the next day to resume negotiations I
could say I'm sorry I've already done
that deal so I was able to establish
that I don't move on price and it worked
for a while until the guy and I became
really good friends we ended up doing
300 deals together over a 20-year
lifespan so a lot of transactions about
50 deals or so into it he said Joel says
I just got to tell you I like to
negotiate price I don't feel good unless
I can negotiate price so if you want it
to be a million dollars tell me it's a
million fifty just tell me it's a
million fifty I'll come back with a
million and then we'll both feel good
and so we negotiated that the last 250
deals we did I would go in about five or
eight percent higher than what I would
accept he would not get down he'd feel
good and I'd feel good so you're kind of
going in and having sort of a sort of a
reasonable buy a route what I'm calling
our Oro rules of the road if you're
going to have serial negotiations with
somebody develop rules of the road
senior partner departure this is a
situation there was a billion dollar
transaction so it's a big deal
and this was 15 or 20 years ago so it's
a very significant transaction and the
partner came to me and said you know I
want to let's agree going into this
negotiation let's agree on values let's
agree what these properties are worth
and then we'll make the trade and on
this particular case I thought you know
the biggest mistake we could make was
would be to agree on the values let's
disagree on the values so you set up
whatever you know the property is better
than I do
you value them however you wish and then
I'll select and the very fact that we
didn't agree on values allowed me to
select deals where I thought I was
getting more than my fair share he then
was able to because he said dies he was
fine with with the deal because he'd
represented what the values were and was
just applying the percentage to the
values he'd set so we were able to get a
transaction done my departure so I left
the CRO organization with the reputation
of being a conciliator with the
reputation of being reasonable with the
reputation of being a win-win deal dried
settled all the litigation that crow had
had for 20 years departing partners I
was seen as somebody who was litigation
averse and because that had become my
brand my negotiating brand when it came
to that they filed litigation against me
realizing that he'll never fight this
guy's such a [ __ ] such a conciliator
he's such a giver and he'll make
everything but that I really had no
place to go
I had set myself up with my brand so I
want from that I want you to think very
carefully about the brand you want to
have the last story is one that I think
you'll remember we live before years of
litigation so I now have a new brand I'm
now known as the ferret
no it's it's interesting because I think
what my brand has become is I am
somebody who is very reasonable who will
do win-win negotiations on but if you
get to the point where you cross me and
my principles or if you do something
that I really think is completely unfair
that I become very stiff so you don't
want to get into litigation with me but
you don't need to so that's that's a
better brand than the brand I had before
which was the guy will never sue he will
never get into litigation so you really
want to think carefully because that
brand and part of my message here is
that there are no episodic negotiations
you may think it's an episode you may
think you're going in and having a
one-off
deal with somebody that person talks to
somebody else who talks to somebody else
who talks to somebody else and pretty
soon everything is get we live in a very
connected world so think carefully if
you're doing a lot of negotiation for a
living
think very carefully about the brand you
want to have now I apologize to my
students former students for this next
one because several have you have seen
this but I had a a negotiation with my
daughter over this last topic so I'm out
here teaching at Stanford and I come out
for basically ten weeks when I teach
here and so she's back in another state
and we correspond by email I get back a
couple of times she and my wife get out
a couple of times but we're basically
away from each other so here I get this
email from her dear dad you hear that
I'm getting a rat would that be cool the
pet store lady said that you can train
rats to fetch and stay I wanted to get
mice because they're cuter and don't
have this disgusting tail but mice just
run away and they never become your
friends rats will sleep on you and I'm
sure dad you'll become great friends
with my rats
I'm thinking of naming them ritzy and
scraps
won't that be cute and you can even see
them when they're tiny babies take deep
breaths if you're getting nervous I will
pay for them and the cage with my very
own money all you and Mom have to do is
buy the food which really doesn't cost
much I've already done everything else I
think I'm ready it's okay I can take
care of them I proven I can take care of
animals I even sweep up the cat's barf I
can handle it so you can trust me to
take care of ritzy and scratch the area
of names I hope you're doing well at
Stanford isn't this warm and fuzzy I'm
doing well here same normal things
practicing soccer whining to mom about
getting rats just so you know she
already said yes is this a negotiator
this is 11 year old kid I mean so some
of this stuff when I asked her who are
the expert negotiators I promise you we
are born knowing something about
negotiations just see oh no sherry oh
yeah I'm sure she's sick of the same
conversations can I get a rat mom please
I'll do my practicing that's my secret
in life promise to do my practicing love
ELISA
so here's this this is the initial
volley this is the negotiating position
she's kind of laid out her negotiating
position so you're sitting out here
1,500 miles away thinking no way she has
crossed a barrier I'm unwilling to cross
so here's my response and I want you to
notice this because this is an ago this
is a real-life negotiation and I'm gonna
have you predict out came out what's
that good point dear Elise are you nuts
I've been killing rats at the house in
Woodside they are not cute they're not
nice they're not controllable they stink
they eat everything they make a little
back poops everywhere and I have to
clean up the mess just this week I
bought some decon they put out where the
rats live
the next day I found a dead rat near the
pool and another one trapped in the
garage just to be clear how about how I
feel I must inform you that we smashed
its head and
I'm a negotiator come on
it was fat and ugly by the way I think
it's name was something like ritzy
in any event one of the big reasons I
was getting so excited about coming home
was to get away from the rat so now I
may as well stay huh
see how hurt I'm just hurt I'm appealing
to this young daughter now what would
you like next a Python or how about some
Ebola virus maybe you could raise
maggots anyway I still love you and miss
you and we'll see you next week well
yeah so how did this negotiation come
out predict okay she it's the rats
exactly she got the rats
now why would an expert professional
negotiator with ten billion dollars
worth of deals under my belt give in to
this 11 year old kid on some stinking
rats that's a great point besides her
mom had already said yes so a real
imbalance of power to me this is the
difference between knowing the elephants
in the ants you know I was willing to
lose a battle to win the war and the war
what I want to winning for me defining
winning for me was raising a child who's
responsible who loves me who will listen
to me on things that really do matter
and so I was really willing to kind of
take a different this now get now that
really gratifying part about this story
is in the end she gave the rats back to
the pet store lady after the pet store
lady had told her she would be feeding
them to the snakes so she disliked the
rats as much as I did in the end and she
came away saying dad you were right
about the rats
so now
um she I arrived home and the rats were
there it's a genteel mom had already
said yes it was do you want to hold them
dad no I think I'll pass on so I think
we've covered most of these this idea of
episodic versus serial think cereal in
your mind as you think about your brand
outside versus inside this last was a
very much of an inside negotiation
you'll have negotiations with third
parties and with people who are really
close whether they're employees partners
brothers sisters children spouses the
inside ones are by far the toughest
negotiations they're the least forgiving
and the most important ones to lose so
this idea that every negotiation is a
competitive game you have to win it
really helps you get over the more
inside negotiations you do in your life
the more that you realize you don't have
to win certainly not every deal point
and you don't have to win every
negotiation so don't think of it as a
competitive game this idea about so like
I just like this quote don't wrestle
with pigs you get dirty and they enjoy
it so be very careful who you negotiate
with and that means generating options
that means always having other people to
talk with and to do business with it is
the worst thing in life is to get in
business with people that don't have the
same values you have but you don't
respect I mean it is misery it's a
different kind of misery from just about
everything you know except being married
to somebody who makes you miserable then
this idea of being reputation building
I've given you my examples of that but
here are some alternative reputations
you have one is I'm tough I'm unbending
the legal documents governed I've known
a lot of people who are that way and
often they're people who have a lot of
money and a lot of law attorneys and
they really believe that's the smart way
to do is it guess what happens in the
end they may not have a lot of money
they may not have the same
of power and they may not have a friend
when things go against them live by the
sword die by the sword
you can be flexible be reopen open to
reworking the the life company joint
venture partner I told you about who
just said take notes Joel turns out he
was one of the most flexible partners
you could ever have so the documents
were the documents were the documents he
couldn't negotiate them he didn't want
you to negotiate just take notes but
when it came to working out the problems
of living in the real world of doing
business he was extraordinarily flexible
and so I kept doing business with him I
probably did 25 deals with him over my
life in real estate because he was such
a great partner it was a tough
negotiator documenter but he was a great
partner you can have this reputation of
being eager to make deals where you just
say I do a lot of singles and doubles I
don't do home runs the other is that
people there are some people in the
negotiating world who just say I only do
home runs if I don't get a four-bagger
if I don't hit a home run if I don't win
the thing that's those are the only
deals I'll do so you need to decide what
your reputation is there we've talked
about these last couple the last one is
this Fisher Fisher and ury trained
problem solver and will talk for a
second about Fisher and ury yeah Connor
basically being selected what you do
where let's just say there is a vendor
that you need to crush it and they don't
agree with their values yeah what do you
do with that kind of situation it's okay
so you just have to suck it up and
negotiate with them in some cases you
can get another party in the
organization you negotiate with in other
cases you can talk to them and say okay
here's where I think our conflict is
going to get to a deeper level and talk
with him about I used to a partner that
would say to people you know we're not
making a deal on this what would it take
to make a deal and that was effective in
certain circumstances you know what
would it take to get this relationship
on a better footing or to develop a more
long-lasting give take relationship and
sometimes you can get that real with
people my view is going back to the very
beginning is generate options so you
don't have one vendor that you really
rely on or one alternative source of
financing or one I mean I like having a
lot of options so and I realized that's
a bit of a Pollyanna you can't always do
that I mean that we just did a deal in
one of the companies I'm involved in
where that they were about 40% of our
business
they were really import we had to get
that deal done so consequently we took
notes and got the deal done so you're
going to do some of it there is not a
panacea at every negotiating problem you
are going to deal with difficult people
you're going to have win lose
negotiations you're going to have some
things that you dread whatever but I'm
just saying you can nudge it so that
it's a happier experience it's a more of
a win-win experience and a better you
choose parties so here here mindsets
that I've got when I go into negotiation
what time do we end Marcelo with Marcel
go at 12 so we have tilt what are you
happy until then or people wanting to
get out of here we're okay
let's talk a little bit about these and
one of the come one of the mindsets that
I think is a really good mindset is that
a negotiation is just a conversation
it's just an exchange you're good at
under sessions you talk to people all
the time so this idea of oh my gosh
we're going into a room we're closing
the doors we're sitting on opposite
sides of tables you know that feels a
lot more threatening than I'm just going
to talk about our various interests and
try to have a conversation to come up
with something that's mutually
satisfying so think of negotiations as
conversations and you're good at think
of negotiations is a series we've
mentioned think that agreements at six
winning its back to this idea of what is
winning the idea is that your agreement
should be durable there's no point in
coming to an agreement that it
terminates in a lawsuit
six months later you've not negotiated a
good agreement so you want them to there
to be some elasticity some sense and
usually that is a function of how much
trust you've developed with your
opposite party if you've developed very
high trust with your opposite party once
you come to an issue the first instinct
isn't oh my gosh let's go to the
documents one of the documents say most
of the good deals I've ever made have
never once referred back to the
documents not once and some of these
things have lasted 2530 years I mean my
whole business career we never ever once
go to the documents why because we like
and trust each other and these are real
issues and we sit down and we talk it
through so you want a durable agreement
so that's that's another mindset to have
another mindset is this thinking win win
another one is to recognize that you're
accountable too a lot of times people
think is the negotiator they're only
accountable themselves I'm winning for
me
they're very rare negotiations where you
don't have broad accountability it's
your employees it's to the community
it's to shareholders it's to a board
sometimes this can be a very effective
not in the room party that you can use
to give you you some breathing room to
pause and say well I can't I wouldn't
feel right about this because of you the
community I don't really feel good about
dumping this sludge into the river you
know I mean you really have an
accountability so this idea that there's
an accountability outside your
interests is a good mindset to have
watching your language I don't think it
works - curse scream swear slam doors
walk out of rooms even bluff
I think bluffing is a fool's game
because all you need to do is Bluff once
and have it not happen and you have
spent your reputation you are forever
more seen as a bluffer so my my view on
that is just never blood never use what
I call high velocity words just you
think of the words that just sort of
raise people's emotional tension and
their temperature just stay away from
them and if somebody uses them on you
ignore it don't let it work on you don't
let your temperature rise so watch your
language and watch annual you've said
you get frustrated you're not going to
forget you have to do that you try to
control it at all cost I think you
should try to control it and here's why
you know if you and as part of it as
you're setting a baseline you know
whatever your baseline is it's the
variation from your baseline that will
get effect so if I say to you I will
never agree to that that's pretty
powerful if you know if you've
negotiated with me a lot of times for me
to say I will never do that I mean you
really believe I just screamed that out
whereas if I'm throwing things around
and cursing and you know a lot of
histrionics I can shout I'll never do
that and you'll say yeah okay he'll come
back tomorrow so I think keeping the
baseline keeping the baseline really low
is a very smart they do plus it keeps
your own blood pressure down I did walk
out of it this billion dollar deal that
I did out here where we were swapping a
billion dollars worth of property i sat
with the partners in the room there were
six of them and one of me and the most
senior of them just said something that
was just completely off the wall and
unfair and I just stood up I said
gentlemen it's been a pleasure to be
your partner all these years I'm so sad
it has to end this way I'm catching my
plane and I'll be gone give me a call in
Dallas if you want to talk about this it
was that simple before I could get to
the airport I had a call from three of
these partners to say please come back
we wanted to go shoot this and it wasn't
that I'd I had gotten up I'd stood up
when they said I'd left the room but my
speech was really that calm and I think
they took that as oh my gosh he is
serious he is really serious and that's
the message that I'm really serious
that's the one I wanted to get across
not that I'm chapped and I'm out of
control or because people don't trust
that as much in the end this idea of
being trusted you know if you really
want to be an effective negotiator be
trusted if the other party can trust you
over the long run you'll develop that
brand and you'll develop durable
agreements high trust relationships
creative solutions relationships with
others that you like etc so I'm just
recommending it as a it's a different
mindset than a lot of people have
towards it yeah into something are you
less in Europe I work all over the world
getting angry may may not work but it's
not a big surprise when it happens the
rest of the world I mean if you're
always calm it translates across all
cultures yeah yeah it's kind of a
universal language clarity or something
in some cultures
absolutely oh no and you've lost and
completely burned on your credibility in
this credibility yeah you're seen as an
unstable person here people might or may
not forgive you depending on the
industry you know some industries are
full of wild people yeah we negotiate do
it through an intermediary investment
banker or an agent or an attorney who's
actually negotiating an agreement would
would you use this as a model for fine
for selecting intermediary because that
person you can often have a tremendous
impact on your branch as well because
they might act completely they're off on
their own you don't really know exactly
what you either I think you have to be
very careful and who you select because
they carry your brand I've seen more
attorneys follow up deals than actually
facilitate deals in fact I select my
attorneys in terms of our they deal
facilitators are they deal makers
problem solvers or are they sort of ego
maniacs who throat we have to be right
on every deal point we have to draft the
toughest document a lot of times you
what you'll do in deals is you'll get
attorneys fighting and the attorneys
will fight and it'll destroy the deal in
the relationship so I number one is I
try not to have very many intermediaries
on the front line I don't like to have
agents brokers investment bankers or
attorneys negotiating my deals I like to
establish a one-on-one relationship with
the other principle in deals I really
think that's the safest way to maintain
your brand and it's the way to create
better relationships to create better
outcomes it's more work in the short run
it's less work in the long run I think
there is a reason that people use these
intermediaries and I think they can be
valuable I think it's always smart to
have somebody outside the room because
negotiations are these real time things
where you're exchanging things back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
you can make mistakes and it really
helps to have somebody whether it's a
board a partner an attorney or whatever
who can come in refine correct smooth
over so I like to use them in all those
things that a lot of times I'll say
I need to run this by my partners or
I'll need to I'd be this makes sense to
me but let me check with the attorney or
Tax Counsel or my accountant on this so
you know I like to have a little bit of
a background so I use them that way but
I never put them say my attorney you'll
negotiate with your attorney and make a
deal like it's very dangerous it's not
to say it doesn't work the other
question regarding this thank you I'm
not not really going above or below this
and as someone I'm very emotive that's
who I am and what what I'm hearing is
you know pokerface try not to get hooked
into these things try not to be
emotional which to me is really like if
you said the best way to negotiate is if
you're six foot tall and I'm five feet
tall so that to me it's like okay I
agree I can see how that would be
effective how'd you just not sixty Phil
yeah I'm not sixty I think you start out
by being yourself authenticity is
something that will be measured by the
opposing party which will go back to
trust a lot I'm just saying that the you
can modulate you can you can keep the
swings from being so wild and and that
will help you you know will make you six
feet tall but it may make you five foot
two I think you need to be yourself
I mean I'm demonstrative too I mean I
speak with my hands I wander around I
get I get excited about idea
I mean it's Who I am so I be I am that
but I just say there are certain things
there are certain certain thresholds
that I don't want to cross because I
spend a lot if I crush those thresholds
I've spent something that doesn't return
to me what it's worth so if you're all
over the map and around like that you
just need to realize you're spending
something that's pretty valuable and and
you don't have anyplace to go
you know once you've cranked the volume
up all the way there's no place to go so
leave yourself a place to go and I think
moderating then the final one is be
likeable and I know this is I mean you
didn't come to Stanford to here be
likeable but I when I went through
litigation I remember talking with I
think it was opposing counsel
after it was all over again and he said
something like you know I wanted to
dislike I wanted to hate you I really
want to be as angry at you as the
plaintiff was he said but I couldn't
help but kind of liking you and he said
in an influence he said I didn't want it
influencing I'm a professional and I did
my job but it still had an impact so I
talked to my attorney about it he says
you know I've had the same experience
where I've gone and he'd he'd deposed
Ivan Boesky I mean you go down the list
people he'd been through a whole bunch
of and he said you know certain of them
were really likable scoundrels and it
made a difference and others you know
you just wanted to fry and so this idea
there is something you know even the
most jaded professionally trained
litigator who does gladiating for for a
life you know says it makes a difference
if you like the other party so I think
there is almost no upside in being a
jerk in being a turkey I just don't
think it gets you anywhere well we're
about out of time I well let's just see
if we've got any more of these we've
talked about agents being a principal
we've talked about lawyers as
memorialize errs or agents disputes you
know this is in the far end of the
formal end of negotiation whether you
mediate arbitrate or litigate I guess my
advice on that is they're all kind of
bad outcomes and you really want to have
what you really want durable flexible
agreements and Trust relationships if
you have to get to these litigation and
arbitration are not that different in
terms of arbitration maybe a little
shorter and a little less expensive but
you're still presenting information
under rules of evidence typically to a
special master or a rented judge or
something so it's a very much the same
kind of thing mediation that negotiation
is a split the baby negotiation so if
you're right you're going to lose
half so I think you you just want to be
so this is again in this very style of
the style I formalized way the rules of
those negotiations very much narrow your
outcomes so just to be aware
implementing the agreement flushing out
hidden agenda items outburst from
material that we've kind of talked about
all of those I think so Fisher and ury
as everybody in here read how many of
you read getting to yes only a few of
you but maybe so old that people don't
read it it's still the classic book let
me go shall we recommend it to all of
you we want to become a better
negotiator written in 1981 by Fisher and
ury to Harvard lawyers and they talk
about their negotiation in the salt
talks and a lot of data on really sort
of what works and what doesn't they
wrote another book called getting past
no so getting to yes is the first one
getting past no is the segment actually
the second one though much less read in
fact is there anybody in here that's
read getting past okay great
not very many people have read it it's
actually I think even a better more
insightful book if you've done a lot of
negotiating those are to really sort of
good practical academic texts that give
you a good map and I can usually tell
when I'm negotiating with somebody who
has studied URI and Fischer it's a
different kind of a negotiation it's
actually quite pleasant so here's the if
you don't want to read it here's the
Reader's Digest version and saving you
time you thought you were wasting an
hour with me I'm going to save you a
couple hours basically the idea is
separate the pit so here are the four
fundamentals separate the people from
the problem which a lot of people don't
do they merge him you know the problems
thorny therefore I don't like the people
the people who have this issue that is
brought before me because I don't like
the issue or it's putting me in an
awkward position I also don't like those
people so a lot of confusion so they say
separate those two then focus on
interests not position in other words
what would you like to see happen not
what position are you going to take or
the other party going to take because
positions are not necessarily related to
what are really in your interests people
express
positions that may not be the actual end
point that reflects their interest then
invent options together for mutual gain
where you think outside the box you
invent options and then insist if you
can this is the hardest one for me it's
figuring out objective criteria you know
what what would be a winning deal what
would work and then assess your deal
against these objective criteria that is
the hardest one for me but I've seen it
work and then finally for me I'd say
know your Batna figure it out write it
out know what going in and my corollary
to that is calculate the other party's
bet so you really know that it's not
life or death there are alternatives and
you'll be more likely to have successful
negotiations now I'm going to show you
there these are the again more Fisher
and ury things but if you'll just this
is how they deal with some of these
dealing with problems and framing things
so I'm going to flash this slide up and
one other slide up and then have you
think about what else this relates to
you know discuss each other don't blame
the opponent see the opponents
intentions
see the situation you know from their
perspective give them a stake in the
outcome
you know don't react to provocation step
away don't respond reflexively be an
active listener agree when you can I
just have a friend that I negotiate a
guy that became a friend that I
negotiated with who would start at every
negotiation with all of the things we
agreed on so you'd go through ten items
it'd say okay we agree on this we agree
on and you got in this reflexive habit
of just agreeing okay I agree to that
that works I agree to that that works
okay that's good and you'd get down to
it then number eleven and twelve and
thirteen which were the tough ones so
these are things that you're in Fisher
discuss and what it you know I guess
I'll just tell you because we were out
of time
my take on this is this is marriage you
know this is how I've made a marriage
work for 35 years is basically doing
these things and and most of the
relationships you're in
are subject to negotiation if you kind
of listen to these best practices your
life will work better your relationships
will work better and your conversations
will be happier your agreements will be
more durable and most of the time you'll
feel like you won most of the time you
won't feel dirty like you need to take a
shower and negotiations won't be just
eating your broccoli but will be
something that gives you life Electric
express creativity and build
relationships so I'll hang around here
after if any of you want to discuss this
or have any questions but thank you very
much